in the era when politics will unite in Poland
are more emotional than reason
heads should be cooled
You should sit down and ask
Count first of all
Does the European Union pay off in Poland?
A prudent politician
A wise man at all
cannot be held hostage by an alternative
The Right Political Line
because the greatest forces
Whether inside the state or outside.
They put such pressure
Today such a different tomorrow
The day after tomorrow even more diverse
and fikko no yy
He who is wise is above this variation.
no matter where the wind blows different
and all his efforts are focused on achieving the chosen goal
in our case it is a Polish good
not legitimizing in public space
Our behavior
our attitudes of non-alternative situations
There is always a way